I talk to my parents and I bring them up
as just kind of General Normie watch the
MSNBC but they're very smart they're
very adaptable to new information but
they tend to watch just the TV instead
of the internet for their news they
don't and uh I was like this this
migrant this immigration thing is
horrific and they're like yeah it is
horrific both of them and they get their
news from like MSNBC but they were like
is Absolut it's it's too far like what
in the hell is happening kind of thing
like easily that I could I could
probably convince them to not vote for
the guy that's causing it to happen is
going to be the issue that I think
jenzie is going to really wake up to too
because once they see that these
immigrants are the ones that are taking
spaces in America taking over the cities
our cities are increasing in crime and
your tax dollars are directly funding
the immigration crisis as well I mean
Texas had no other choice but to enact
Article 1 Section 10 in the Constitution
because the federal government isn't
doing anything about it and honestly the
federal government hates American people
more than Democrats I think hate
American people